so some of the standard questions that
we've examined already about random
graphs are the probability of getting
from one place to another or the
expected time to get from one place to
another but a different kind of question
that comes up in a fundamental way is
the probability of being someplace so
let's examine that here is the graph
with a states blue orange and green that
we've seen before and suppose that I
start at state B and I ask what's the
probability of being at each of these
states after one step so to start with
I'm interested in PBP o + PG which is
the probability of being at state B the
probability of being at state o and the
probability of being at state G the sum
of the probabilities is going to be one
and initially when I tell you that I'm
at state B it means the probability of
being at B is 1 and the other two is 0
and I'm interested in the way that these
probabilities update after one step if P
prime B is the probability of being in
state B after one step and P prime 0 o
is the probability of being in the
orange state one step later and likewise
for green what are these probabilities
well it's easy to see just reading off
this graph that the only place you're at
is B so the only way to get probability
of being somewhere is by looking
following an edge out of B so the
probability of being at one step at the
orange vertex is 1/4 and it's like wise
1/4 for being at the green state and
it's 1/2 for staying at the blue state
so what we can say is that the updated
probabilities of being at these
different states is 1/2 1/4 and 1/4 as
we've just reasoned ok let's keep going
given that the probability that I'm at
the States blue orange and green are
given by this vector of probabilities
what's the distribution after 2 steps so
let P double prime B be the probability
of being in state B after 2 steps
starting from B well the way we can
figure that out
is by using conditional probabilities
let's look at the example of the
probability calculating the probability
of being in the orange state two steps
after you've started at the blue state
so here is the probabilities of being at
the different states after one step how
do I get to the arn state well I can get
to the orange state from the blue state
and so the probability of being in the
orange state after two steps is the
probability of being at the blue state
after one step times the probability
that I take this edge to the orange
state that is it's the probability of
going from B to Oh
given that I'm at B times the
probability of being in B after one step
this then is the probability of being
and Oh after two steps and likewise the
probability of being oh another
component of the probability of being at
O is that if you're a toe and you what's
the probability of going from o to O and
that is this one third times the
probability of being at all at all which
is a quarter and the final case using
again took the law of total probability
breaking it up into cases the third way
that I can get to the iron state on step
two is by being at the green state on
step one following the green to O edge
of which there isn't any so that's gonna
be probability zero times the
probability of being at the green state
which is a quarter but it won't matter
so let's just fill in these amounts
looking at the first term the
probability of going from B to o when
you're at B is simply the probability of
this edge it's a quarter and likewise
the probability of going from o to O
given that you're at O is the
probability of this edge namely a third
so we can fill that term in and finally
the probability of going from G to O is
zero given that you're at G because
there isn't any vertex there and then
you fill in those probabilities and
do the arithmetic you come out with a
five twenty fourth problem probability
of being in the orange state after two
steps well the same calculation you can
figure out what's the probability of
being at the blue state or the green
step after two steps and there's the
answer there's a 50/50 chance of being
in the blue state after two steps five
twenty fourth as we saw at the orange
state and the rest of it it is seven
twenty fourth is the probability of
being at the green state okay so what's
going on in general and we can explain
how to do these calculations by using a
little bit of linear algebra so let's
define the edge probability matrix of a
random walk graph is just the adjacency
matrix of the graph except that instead
of using zeros and ones to indicate
whether an edges not present or present
I'll use in that in the put in the IJ
position of the matrix the probability
of the edge that goes from I to J if
there is an engine zero if there isn't
any edge let's look at an example so
here is the way we would fill it in
abstractly for our three state graph
it'll be a three by three matrix with
the probabilities of the successive
edges in the corresponding position so
this is the position in the the BB
coordinate is the probability of the
edge from B to be the Oh B coordinate if
you think of the columns as labeled blue
blue orange green and the Roses labeled
blue orange green this is the orange
blue coordinate and it's the probability
of the edge from zero to B let's fill in
the first row which was this is just red
directly off the graph it was the edges
out of B that went from B to B from B to
oh and from Beata
great G and it had those weights and if
I fill in the rest of it I get the the
edge probability matrix for our simple
three state graph and there it is so
this last one is the shows the fact that
there is and there's a certain edge from
green to blue the only place you can go
from green is to
below and you can't go to either orange
or green in one step okay so why are we
bringing up the matrix well if you
looked at the way we updated the state
to go from the the one-step distribution
to the toe step distribution it was
really a matrix multiply and in general
to do an update you're just going to do
a vector matrix multiplication if you
have the probabilities of being in the
successive states B oh and G and you
won't do a matrix vector matrix
multiplication using the the probability
matrix of the graph you get the updated
and vector of distributions and that's
easy to check just from the definitions
and from the definition of vector times
matrix which I assume you're familiar
with so now we can ask what's the
distribution after T steps starting from
some particular given distribution say
starting in state B or starting at any
possible distribution of probabilities
to the different states and the way that
we can figure that out so I'm interested
in other words is the probability of
being in oh a fter T steps G after T
steps and bf2 T steps say starting from
state B and what happens also as T
approaches infinity these are sort of
two basic questions that we're going to
be asking so first of all how do you
calculate starting and a given
distribution P bpop G where you're gonna
be after T steps well you're just
continually updating which means if I'm
multiplying by M T times so the
distribution after T steps is gotten by
taking the initial distribution times
the teeth power of M now this is
actually already useful computationally
because it means that since you can
compute a matrix power by successive
squarings
you actually only need about log of T
matrix multiplications in order to be
able to figure out what's the
distribution of probabilities on the
after T steps of the of the graph then
the push
a concept that we want to examine and
we'll make a lot of use of in the next
video and we talked about a PageRank is
the idea of a stationary distribution so
a stationary distribution means that
that once you're in the state a
stationary distribution it's stable
you're gonna say stay in that
distribution you're not gonna be in any
particular state but the but you'll have
a vector of probabilities of being in
the different states and one step later
that vectors not going to change so what
it means is that the next step
distribution is the same as the current
distribution
what's the stable what's a stationary
distribution here well the way we're
gonna have to calculate that is here's
how you update this is the result of the
matrix of the vector matrix
multiplication but let's just spell it
out in terms of the conditional
probabilities after one step if the
original distribution is P B P OPG then
the new probability of being in state B
the only way you can get there is by
being following the edge from B to B
with probability 1/2 and that's times
the probability of being at B and the
other way you can get to B is by being
at the green state and then one step
later you're certain to be at bay so
that adds a contribution of 1 times P G
likewise for a P the updated probability
of being at the orange state in the
green state and what we want is that
these updated probabilities are the same
as the ones that I'm starting with
that's the definition of stability you
update the vector P bpop G and you get
the same vector that's what makes it
stable and of course a side constraint
since you can always solve a system of
equations like this by letting all the
peas be 0 which is degenerate we add the
constraint that the sum of the
probabilities of being in the States has
to be 1 well if we solve the a simple 3
by 3 system of equations then it turns
out that the stable distribution is
there's an 8th 15th being in state B a 3
15th chance of being in state orange and
a 4 15th state chance of being in state
green and
should check that yourself by asking
what's the probability of being in PB
after one step given these probabilities
and I'm not going to talk you through
that but just to verify and imprint the
idea of stability that's one that's
worth stopping the video for a moment to
check and do a little arithmetic with a
pencil and paper okay so in general what
we're going to do is we're trying to
find the stationary distribution vector
called an S bar for vector and we get
this by solving the the vector matrix
equation that the distribution vector
times the edge probability matrix is
equal to that same distribution vector
we want to solve this system of
equations if there are n states then
this is an N by n system of equations
with an additional constraint that we
want the norm of the of the stable
vector to be 1 because that's to avoid
the degenerate zero solution well there
are some problems with stationary
distributions that we want to think
about first of all what happens in this
example where you have just two states
and the probability of being the first
stated one in the second state is 0 well
if you update that state what happens is
you go to this you just go to the second
state with probability 1 and you can
keep doing that and there may be a
stable distribution here but this
particular pattern doesn't converge to
it as you go through time half the time
you're at every other step your state 1
and every other step you're at state 0
but the you never get to the disk to a
stable distribution where step after
step you are at equal probability of
being at these two places I'm assuming
here that this is a certain edge and
that's a certain edge it has to be
there's only one edge out so a stable
distribution would be 1/2 1/2 but this
thing doesn't converge to it ok here's a
slightly more complicated example where
again assume that all the edges are
equally likely there's exactly two edges
out of each
of these vertices so though each edge
has weight 1/2 and the problem with this
graph is that when you ask what's the
stable distribution and well if you look
at it if you assume that the probability
of being in the middle is 0 and the two
places that you get stuck at have
probability P and 1 minus P then that's
stable because once you're at this state
with probability P you're following the
1 certain edge that goes back around to
this vertex and therefore this
probability of P of being there one step
later and likewise probability Q of one
step later so the split between P and Q
is a stable distribution for this thing
with probability 0 and 0 there and of
course P and Q can be any real numbers
between 0 & 1 so there's actually an
uncountable number of stable
distributions for this graph problem
here is it's not strongly connected and
that turns out to be a sufficient
condition that it's got a stable
distribution whenever it's strongly
connected so in general we can ask the
question is there always stable a
stationary distribution for any random
graph well if the graph is finite yes
there's guaranteed to be a stationary
distribution but is it unique
well sometimes sometimes not if the
graph is strongly connected it will be
unique but we've seen examples where in
the previous slide where it's not unique
in fact it could be uncountably many and
another crucial question is does a
random walk approach the stable
distribution no matter how you start and
that first example was one where you
went between the first state and the
second state and isolated and it never
converged on the stable distribution of
1/2 and 1/2 in general it's nice when
you can say that no matter how you start
after a while things stabilize and you
wind up at the unique stable
distribution so sometimes it'll be the
case that every distribution every
initial distribution will eventually
converge on the stable one
the stationary one sometimes not and
then another crucial question will be
how quickly does this convergence happen
if we start off at some arbitrary
probability distribution or some
particular state how long does it take
before by and large the the
probabilities that were in the different
states has become pretty stationary and
the rate at which that happens again
varies depending on the graph